[Musik]
ich glaube nicht dass es einfach wird
ein kredit zu bekommen
das verstehe ich nicht natürlich bin ich
kein reicher mann aber es muss trotzdem
eine möglichkeit geben
erst einmal gibt es kredite nur unter
bestimmten voraussetzungen und kondition
die konditionen sind wir bekannt und
damit bin ich ein fechter ja das ist gut
jedoch muss vor allem die bank mit dir
einverstanden sein
warum sollen sie mit mir nicht
du kannst deine liquidität nicht belegen
außerdem fehlen einkommensnachweise
unterlagen
meine familie und ich sind vor krieg und
tod geflohen
die unterlagen haben wir nicht
mitgenommen hey ich bin auf deiner seite
aber ich kann das system nicht ändern
was brauche ich damit ich einen kredit
aufnehmen kann
ich habe alle unterlagen aber in suhl
ihren die bank braucht eine versicherung
das zu lange genug in deutschland
bleibst um einen kredit zurückzuzahlen
wie soll diese versicherung aus wären es
muss eine losung gehen die gibt ich
bürge für dich ja das bedeutet wenn du
nicht zahlst trage ich die verantwortung
das fuchst du tun was soll schon
passieren
[Musik]
danke gerne